un milliardaire américain a organisé une
énorme pour renouveler ses voeux de
mariage
il a décidé d' ambiance et tout l'avion
c'est les mecs qui font des trucs de ouf
la vie d'un taux pas les mecs vous est
ce que vous allez dire fais un truc de
ouf un jour j'ai dit voilà theekoye
nicon book voilà je casse pour eux elle
ni convoque voilà je fais un truc de ouf
à la voile à bouaké qu'est ce que vous a
déjà fait - vous avez acheté une paire
de pantoufles caisses affectant les voir
moi mes 18 ans gaulliste ex metz martial
un organisme existant gm avait loué une
grande villa de fou tout décoré et va
couiner tout fort occupé à trois mois
ouais c'est normal c'est houphouet une
calèche en quoi elle est l'anniversaire
de malik bentalha quoi il a fait une
semaine d'anniversaire frère c'est vrai
oui c'est vrai ça aussi bah ouais elle
embrasse mali oui vous avez fait quoi
pour demander une femme en mariage j'ai
pris ma voiture je suis parti de paris
je suis allé à milan j'ai acheté la robe
de mariée je suis revenu j'ai déposé lob
sur son lit l'événement était le sens de
mes 30 ans j'ai fait la nouba pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai privatiser
un bar et ce temps non pour moi c'est
très compliqué d'organiser les choses
donc voilà c'est un peu fier de moi je
savais que ça sentait pas d'histoire dès
le début dès que vous avez pris la
parole savez comme je fais la fête c'est
qu'on m'appelle non syrie la nouba ouais
ouais vous êtes productrice de
l'émission
oui c'est pour l'enterrement de vie de
jeune fille de ma petite soeur et
j'avais loué une grande chambre en fait
je connaissais le concierge et m'a fait
pour pas cher et c'est la suite de snoop
dogg dans une sorte de 900 m² c'était un
truc de fou en effet on a fait des
fautes non mais bon on n'était pas
invité un doctorat bêtes là bas lui
savait ce qui m'a un jour fou y'a pas
rigoler pour son anniversaire ses 38 ans
il a privatisé un nicolas
[Rires]
est ce que mon père est avec piscine toi
un joueur de tête c'est un tu veux que
je mette l'excès tu nous dises après un
dépensier d'entre vite ni n'ont rien
estafette acheter un nouveau bonnet
allez je vais te laisser réfléchir
beaucoup
qu'est-ce que je ne pense pas beaucoup
c'est vrai t'as jamais fait une folie
non